now if you've been following covet 19
over the course the last few weeks
you'll have seen a lot of numbers a lot
of data being thrown around some of it's
quite baffling and I'm not a doctor or
an epidemiologist but I know something
about charts and about data so let me
talk you through why some of these data
series really do matter because cope
with 19 the way that it spreads is very
exponential and showing that on charts
is quite difficult I'll show you why
also it's not quite clear how we compare
ourselves either with other countries or
indeed with the past or what metric to
use so initially a lot of people were
looking at this this shows you the
number of cases in the UK just on a kind
of daily basis you can see it mounting
up and if you add all of those together
you come to 20,000 cases positive cases
of Kove at 19 in the UK and actually
that would make the UK look pretty good
wouldn't it so if you compare the UK
with other countries it's lower than
France Germany China and the rest but
there's some issues with this you've
probably already noticed them first of
all the US and the China have much
bigger populations so it's not
necessarily very comparable there is it
and other countries are doing far more
testing so Germany doing a lot more
testing they may well have actually
about the same amount of covert 19 in
Germany but they are certainly detecting
more it through their tests but a better
way of judging what the trajectory for
different countries is is looking at how
many people are dying of the disease and
if you look at that here's a kind of
picture of what we know so far so these
are the cumulative number of people who
have died of covert 19 in the UK over
the course of the last few weeks so
initially that number that line was
doubling every two days so rising quite
steeply then it started to double every
three days so actually slightly less
steeper growth rate but this really
matters because if you carry on growing
at the rate they are there so doubling
every three days number of deaths then
you're heading up before you know it to
20,000 deaths and that's within a
fortnight so from where we are now up to
20,000 deaths could be within a
fortnight if we carry on at that growth
rate that growth rate matters enormously
a lower growth rate so doubling every
four days and you're talking about a
shallower curve and even just doubling
every week which doesn't sound like that
much of a difference does it look at how
much difference it makes look at how
different that line is and that's why
it's all important to think about the
growth
wait not these absolute numbers a lot of
people are focusing on thousands and so
on it's about how fast it's growing and
you can't really see that from this line
so we've got a different way of charting
this it's called the logarithmic chalk
it basically charts growth rates rather
than absolute numbers I'll take the same
data here and convert it to a
logarithmic axis and just have a look at
this exactly the same data and what you
can see is this line it's much steeper
at the start because that's a steeper
growth rate and then it's getting a bit
flatter and then potentially if you're
doubling every week it's getting even
flatter so logarithmic chart in this
case they matter so I'm not a big fan of
them in other parts of data but in this
case it really does matter and it
matters too when you have a look at
what's going on with the UK versus other
countries so some people have talked
about charts like this the UK for
instance the US Germany this is the
number of deaths again look quite low
compared with Spain and Italy don't they
this is just in absolute terms and
that's why a lot of people are focusing
on Spain and focusing on Italy and some
people think there's no problem in
Germany and other countries but convert
this to a logarithmic chart and it's a
very different story have a look at this
same data exactly the same data and what
you can see is that pretty much all of
the countries in Europe certainly the
ones we've got charted here I'm moving
in the same direction even Germany and
the UK and the u.s. the UK is pretty
much heading in line with Italy and if
focusing on the UK for a moment if we
carry on with our growth rate that we
have at the moment so doubling every
three days here's where we're heading
we're actually going to get into a
steeper situation rising towards 10,000
deaths pretty much comparatively before
Italy did that's the power of these
exponential growth rates they are pretty
terrifying and that's why everyone wants
to try and flatten these lines and if
you look at Spain for instance you get a
little bit of hope there glimmer of hope
it's a terrible story in Spain they have
as you can see here a worse situation
than Italy but they instituted lockdown
far earlier so 14th of March there was a
lockdown across Spain because it takes
about two weeks for the disease to take
effect it took a while for this lockdown
to take effect as well so the number of
people dying still continue to double
even after that lockdown every three
days
but recently a fortnight on just over a
fortnight on actually although the
numbers are still horrible the rate at
which this grow
the rate at which death rate number of
people dying as gray is now down so
doubling every six days rather than
every three days a big difference so
suggests they are starting to flatten
that line and that's part of the
strategy in the UK as I mentioned it's
not necessarily clear that countries
like Germany and the Netherlands are
heading in a different direction in fact
they seem to be heading in pretty much
the same direction as everyone else
which suggests that you're going to see
many of the same policies implemented
across Europe it be interesting to keep
an eye on what happens in Sweden because
they're doing it slightly differently
over there I just say this is not the
only way of looking at the numbers and
there are some question marks about
whether what are called covert 19 deaths
are comparable whether they necessarily
are comprehensive so we are going to
keep our an eye on different data series
as well and one of them is this one this
is not just covert 19 deaths in the UK
so it's a weekly series just showing you
the number of total deaths in Britain
why does this matter because we can
chart we can compare look at the bars
versus the dotted line we can compare
how we're doing now with previous years
and if it turns out that these bars
which are slightly below the average of
the last five years that these bars in
the coming weeks start to rise above the
average that suggests there's a real
problem across the UK will be keeping a
close eye on this chart and all of the
other charts because they give us a
sense of where we might be heading in
the course of the next few weeks